ja für Verwirrung sagt mir wieder Karl
Lauterbach immer hat er die Impfpflicht
hochgehalten hartnäckig verteidigt nur
so beenden wir die Pandemie jetzt wieder
die Impfpflicht in Krankenhäusern alten
und Pflegeheimen auslaufen lassen und
das hat er irgendwie seltsam begründet
da schauen wir mal kurz rein
es gab Protest aber das war keine
Grundlage hier für die Änderung es ist
eine reine epidemiologische Überlegung
die Impfung schützt nicht mehr vor der
Ansteckung und wenn sie nicht mehr vor
der Ansteckung schützt dann gibt's auch
keinen Grund mehr in diesen
Einrichtungen trotzdem bleibt es
natürlich dabei die impfungsschutz sehr
gut Moment der Impfstoff schützt nicht
gegen die Ansteckungen noch vor ein paar
Wochen hat er zum Stadt der ins Kampagne
gesagt die Impfung schütze vor der
Ansteckung Herrmann glauben sie den
Gesundheitsminister
schon lange nichts mehr ich war mal das
ist politisch schon für mich ein
gerissen großer Sprung gewesen ich war
mal Lauterbach Fan weil ich ihn halt
auch als Kapazität anerkannt habe ein
Virologe der in den höchsten
universitätskreisen auch höchstes
Ansehen genießt der muss es ja wissen
ich bin ja nicht schlauer als er und ich
habe mich impfen lassen was damals eine
große Schwierigkeit war ich habe die
Tricks und gedreht bis ich meine erste
Impfung hatte ich habe die zweite
Impfung weil ich auch schon Corona hatte
und nach der dritten Impfung hatte ich
noch mal Corona und seitdem bin ich
etwas skeptischer weil er sich das dann
verändert sie ihm gesagt erst wenn sie
noch richtig Fan von ihm war das so sehr
Gesundheitsminister wurde und dann kam
dann der Punkt wo sie gesagt haben also
irgendwie
da sein verabschieden seine Politik rein
in die Kartoffeln raus aus den
Kartoffeln war und als ich das Gefühl
hatte dass er nur und so fokussiert ist
auf korit das alles andere im Bereich
der gesundheitsmedizin plötzlich
sekundär und Tertiär war ich habe
gelesen wie Krankenhäuser vor der Pleite
stehen die gefordert haben wir müssen
uns helfen dass die Pflege den Bach
runter geht das waren aber alles keine
Themen mehr die Lauterbach öffentlich
wahrgenommen hat und seitdem bin ich
kein Fan mehr wie geht's Ihnen mit dem
Thema sie haben sich auch fürs impfende
engagiert haben sie auch ja so eine Art
Meinungsänderung bei dem Thema
durchgemacht vielen im Land ging es ja
so dass Sie Ihre Meinung im Zuge der
Pandemie auch mit mehr Informationen
verändert haben also ich war von Anfang
an fürs impfen und ich glaube es ist
auch nach wie vor sinnvoll ich meine sie
haben ihn ja irgendwie nach der mitten
im Satz sozusagen abgebrochen vermutlich
wollte er ausführen dass die Impfung
zwar nicht voransteckung schützt aber
vor schweren Verläufen das kann ich
schon genau aber das ist etwas haben
jetzt nicht mehr und das glaube ich ist
irgendwie das Pudels Kern es geht ja
auch darum die Leute vor schweren
Verläufen zu schützen und insofern ist
eine Impfung nach wie vor sinnvoll ich
muss aber Herrn Hartmann zustimmen dass
das was Lauterbach angekündigt hat was
er alles regeln wollen wo er dran
arbeiten will wie zum Beispiel an diesem
Fallpauschalen die das ganze
Gesundheitssystem so auf
Wirtschaftlichkeit trimmt aber weniger
darauf was brauchen die Patientinnen und
Patienten um gesund zu werden die
brauchen vor allem aber auch Pfleger die
weiter kommen wird was brauchen die
Leute um gesund zu werden das ist doch
die entscheidende Frage und was muss
dazu bereitgestellt werden und dann
kommt die Frage und wie bezahlen wir das
äh diese Fallpauschalen gegen genau den
umgekehrten Weg die sagen so viel Geld
hat und das müsste irgendwie klären wie
es geht und das führt nur dazu dass die
Krankenhäuser an den rannte
Existenzfähigkeit kommen dass danach
geguckt wird was kann ich teuer
operieren aber nicht was brauchen die
Leute wirklich um gesund zu werden und
da hatte er viel versprochen vor der
Bundestagswahl und jetzt passiert leider
gar nichts insofern
haben ja dann auch gefehlt in der Pflege
jetzt kippt diese Impfpflicht da sind
sie froh
ehrlich gesagt glaube ich nicht dass das
der Hauptpunkt war für den
Personalmangel in der Pflege
und das sind die Arbeitsbedingungen also
es sind die Arbeitsbedingungen wenn man
sich nicht verlassen kann warten welchen
Tagen muss ich wirklich arbeiten wenn
Doppelschichten gefahren werden müssen
wenn zu wenig Leute da sind so dass die
Pflegerinnen und Pfleger gar nicht
wissen habe ich eigentlich alles gemacht
was ich machen muss und ich habe
Verantwortung für Menschenleben das
macht Menschen kaputt und da deswegen
sind viele aus der Pflege rausgegangen
oder sind auf Teilzeit gegangen und
deswegen fehlen uns so viel viele
Pflegekräfte ich glaube wenn wir bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen haben wir sind hier
in Berlin so ein Stück vorangegangen mit
den entlastungs-tarifverträgen an der
Charité und bei unserem kommunalen
Krankenhauskonzern weil Vivantes aber
auch das muss natürlich die täglich neu
wieder erkämpft werden weil man muss ja
auch die Fachkräfte auch erstmal
ausbilden und sie dann auch dafür
gewinnen dass sie dann auch bleiben aber
ich glaube das A und O ist gar nicht mal
unbedingt das Geld auch das Geld ist
wichtig aber die Arbeitsbedingungen
bleiben wir mal beim Thema Impfung und
ich sehe Herr Klaus der Chart schon
bisschen mit den Hufen der möchte gerne
einführen hoffe ich nicht dass Berlin
zum Vorbild für die ganze Bundesrepublik
wird denn hier in Berlin läuft nun
wirklich im Prinzip alles falsch
ich glaube das sehen aber die meisten
Menschen so also in ganz Deutschland
so gewählt wird aber von der Verwaltung
bis auch zur Pflege und dem Verkehr
läuft hier in Berlin wirklich eigentlich
alles schief und die meisten Menschen in
Deutschland wünschen sich nicht das
Berlin übertragen wird auf alle anderen
Bundesländern aber ich will einfach mal
zurück zu ihrer Frage kommen wir haben
ja vor einigen Monaten noch über eine
Impfpflicht diskutiert
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht
generelle Impfpflicht jetzt finde ich
gibt es gar keinen Argument mehr warum
eine Impfpflicht eingeführt werden
sollte weil mittlerweile ja die Pandemie
endemisch geworden ist also wir haben
gelernt mit der mit dem Coronavirus auch
zu leben damit umzugehen das ist jetzt
eine normale Krankheit wie viele andere
auch und deswegen brauchen wir auch
Normalität wenn wir über solche Themen
reden und deswegen finde ich sollten wir
gar nicht jetzt mehr über Impfpflicht
debattieren dass verunsichert er die
Menschen wir haben jetzt gelernt mit dem
Coronavirus zu leben und das was bei
Karl Lauterbach schiefläuft ist dass er
eigentlich Debatten führt und Diskussion
führt die man vor einem Jahr gut führen
konnte aber die jetzt völlig aus der
Zeit gefallen sind gerade gesagt wir
brauchen die Impfpflicht nicht mehr ich
will ihnen allen ihr heute mal einen
Fall zeigen einen Soldaten aber bei uns
am Dienstag hier in der Sendung und der
hat uns dramatisch geschildert was das
mit ihm macht die Impfpflicht in der
Bundeswehr unter welchen Konsequenzen er
zu leiden hat schauen wir mal rein
gemeinsam
ja man versucht mich jetzt halt
rauszukriegen aus der Bundeswehr ich
habe
Akteneinsicht gehabt von meinen Akten
und konnte halt raus lesen dass man mich
einfach sofort gerne entfernen möchte
was aber nicht funktioniert ich bin
schon zu lange dabei das gibt meine
Dienstzeit eben nicht her und
ja man will darauf hinaus dass ich
unernhaft entlassen werde was macht das
mit ihnen das macht mich psychisch
fertig weil ich keinen Ansprechpartner
habe es gibt ja keinen der mit mir
darüber reden kann sondern ich bin da
eher auf mich allein gestellt und werde
allein gelassen auch in Dienst es gibt
da niemanden die sind alle eher so ganz
vorsichtig bei dem Thema Weise alle
Angst haben dass irgendwas Falsches
gesagt wird und ja da habe ich bei mir
eben nur die Familie und meine Verlobte
mit der ich da ein bisschen reden kann
eben gerade gesagt wir brauchen die
Impfpflicht nicht mehr für die
Bundeswehr gilt sie weiter in der Städte
überhaupt nicht zu Debatte die muss man
doch konsequenterweise jetzt auch dort
abschaffen oder nicht also ich bin auch
dafür dass man jetzt keine Impfpflicht
mehr verhängt das war vor einem Jahr
fand ich gab es durchaus Argumente auch
dafür aber da hatten wir auch eine ganz
andere Lage wenn wir über das
Coronavirus gesprochen hatten und jetzt
haben wir gelernt damit zu leben jetzt
wieder nach der Sendung ein erneuten
impfbefehl bekommen der muss am Montag
da antanzen und sich impfen lassen er
hat uns sein im Heft gezeigt es ging
alles geimpft aber er möchte die
corona-impfung ich stehen sie dem Mann
jetzt bei also ich finde dass man solche
Leute nicht so unter Druck setzen sollte
oder dass solche Leute deswegen sogar
aus dem Dienst ausschalten müssen also
ja ich stehe bei gut dann gehen wir nach
der Sendung gebe ich mal ihr Kärtchen
weiter er gab von wie wird das auf Sie
diese Diskussion die Impfpflicht also
jetzt zumindest einrichtungsbezogen soll
fallen
vor einem Jahr genau vor einem Jahr hat
er Lauterbach gesagt Weihnachten werden
wir Intensivstation übervoll haben die
werden wieder für die Leichen die
herauszutransportieren sind falls nicht
sofort der Unfug kommt es tat nicht ein
und so können sich eine Vielzahl von
Momenten schildern während dieser
gesamten Kampagne mir konnte bis heute
keine erklären was ist eigentlich mit an
oder mit Corona gestorben wo ist die
Differenzierung bei den Krankenschein
wissen sie das merkt man die Absichten
ist verstimmt hat einfach zu viele
Impfstoffe bestellt weiß auch keiner
genau wie wir von alleine das
hingekriegt hat die sind ja alle
vertraulich darf keiner reinschauen
wissen sie das riecht verdammt nach
Korruption muss ich ihn ganz offen sagen
und wenn er lauter macht sich heute hin
stellte ist sozusagen ein Dauer Inventar
deutscher Talkshows da lässt sich dann
andere Dinge muss man da nicht reden
Corona ist für den Mann wie ein Stück
Zucker am Morgen deswegen hat er halt
heute wieder nachgelegt und ich kann das
alles nicht mehr glauben das ganze ist
aus meiner Sicht eine Mischung aus
personelle die Show und wirklich
Verdummung der Bevölkerung ich warte bis
heute auf dem Untersuchungsausschuss dem
angekündigt wurde von der Union aber die
Hänger selber mit drin war ja Minister
da da nicht nee doch selbstverständlich
wurde in der Opposition sein gab es sehr
viel Kritik und dann wurde gesagt und
die FDP vor allen Dingen ist davon
gegangen also die Union nie einen
untersuchungsangehörigen
mindestens auch solche Stimmen gab
vielleicht im Verborgenen hinter
vorgehalten hat damit Mutti ist nicht
hört oder andere aber auf jeden Fall ist
das kritisch heute ist darüber alles ein
Tuch gedeckt und ich finde das einfach
unglaubwürdig und noch eins möchte ich
Samstag Debatte mir fällt auf das immer
auf das System abgehoben wird das System
ist schuld die Finanzierung als immer
der Staat reden wir doch mal über
Menschen ich kenne Menschen die in der
Pflege gearbeitet haben hat ihnen Mal
haben sie mal gefragt warum dort wo die
Krankheit am gegenständlichsten ist
Menschen sehen kranke Menschen auch im
Intensivbereich waren die höchste Quote
der impfverweigerer und hier in Berlin
sind Entlassungen erfolgt in Brennpunkt
klingen ich weiß es weil eine Bekannte
von mir davon betroffen war die hat
gesagt ich lasse mich nicht impfen
lieber gehe ich also wissen sie das ist
eine hochideologisierte Debatte die dann
auch da kamen diese Corona Leugner zu
den gehöre ich nicht aber dass jeder der
einen Kritik gemacht hat gleich nach
Rechtsaußen abgestempelt wurde wissen
sie das aber ja leider ein beliebtes
Motiv können wir auch aus anderen Banken
Migrationen ne wie geht's mir gar nicht
wir könnten das beliebig fortsetzen wir
sind die Spitzen Leute die immer das
System Anklagen und den Menschen aus dem
vorlassen Punkt eins klassisch linke
Ideologie und zweitens haben
[Gelächter]
gemacht der Wand jetzt schon wieder
er Lauterbach der Wand jetzt schon
wieder vor der winterwelle also das ist
so ein bisschen history repeating haben
wir was gelernt aus der Zeit oder etwa
nicht also ich bin keine virologin ich
bin auch keine Medizinerin das was ich
lese und ich habe auch Herrn Drosten
gelesen der jetzt gesagt hat wir kommen
tatsächlich wie sie sagen in eine
endemische Phase und es ist
unwahrscheinlich dass wir wieder in
solche Wellen kommen dass der
Intensivstationen überlastet sind oder
die Krankenhäuser überlastet werden oder
das alte und mehrfach
empfindliche Menschen davon besonders
betroffen sein werden insofern würde ich
auch eher dazu raten ähm
einigermaßen gelassen damit umzugehen
und dennoch dazu anzuhalten und zu
motivieren die Menschen aufeinander
Rücksicht zu nehmen ich finde die
maskenpflicht im öffentlichen Nahverkehr
wo man sich zum Teil sehr nahe kommt
finde ich richtig
ich finde auch das ist keine
Menschenrechtsverletzung zum damaligen
öffentlichen Person Nahverkehr also
Nahverkehr weil da bleibt man ja in der
Regel nicht so lang also in Berlin schon
war ein bisschen länger wenn man
irgendwie von Spandau bis
Treptow-Köpenick will dann dauert länger
weil es ist einfach mich interessiert
noch wie stehen Sie zu den Soldaten wie
stellen Sie zu den Soldaten
weil ich habe hier einen Bildausschnitt
von 30 Sekunden gesagt
ja Geschichte noch die
Hintergrundgeschichte er unterliegt er
Impfpflicht weil er Soldat in der
Bundeswehr ist und der dort geht die
Impfpflicht weiterhin am Montag hat er
seine nächsten Befehle ist vor Gericht
gezogen hat wahnsinnige Probleme Bedarf
psychischer Behandlung so wird er unter
Druck gesetzt es geht die Impfpflicht er
muss sich weiterhin impfen lassen finden
Sie das sinnvoll
da muss ich sagen der schlagen zwei
Herzen in meiner Brust weil natürlich
gibt es auch in anderen Bereichen
impfpflichten also wer Erzieher oder
Erzieherin sein will der muss eine
Masernimpfung vorweisen können und
andere
Impfung
wie die andere und Ende ist doch also
es ist gibt es eine corona-impfung eine
Masernimpfung eine zu meiner Zeit gab es
noch pockenimpfungen das sind alles
Impfungen ich bin auch gegen Tetanus und
Diphtherie und symbolio und so weiter
geimpft sind sinnvolle Impfungen die im
übrigen auch dafür schützen dass man
andere ansteckt so diese
malenschutzimpfung ist zum Beispiel
vorgeschrieben
so werden sich
entscheideckung genau
bestimmten Beruf auszuüben und da gibt
es bestimmte Auflagen da muss ich dann
halt auch überlegen
in einigen Punkten ist das ja sinnvoll
also ich weil bei Masern brauchen wir
glaube ich gar nicht diskutieren weil da
geht es tatsächlich darum das mag sein
aber ich würde jetzt sein in der Runde
nicht bei am Anfang der Debatte war das
Argument alle sollen sich impfen lassen
um Ansteckung zu vermeiden und das wenn
es so wäre wäre das wenn ich ein sehr
starkes Argument nur ist das hier nicht
der Fall ne und deswegen finde ich kann
man das nicht mit dem masernen deswegen
werfen wir diese Frage ja auf aber ich
höre schon raus ihr kennt darf ich
weitergeben an
sonsten
Unterstützung aber zumindest das haben
aber das war jetzt Politik mit einem
entschiedenen vielleicht sowohl als auch
eventuell aber eine Sache aber ich
verspreche ungern Dinge die ich gar
nicht halten kann
die Bundeswehr das für sich so definiert
dass diese Impfpflicht notwendig ist
gibt es vielleicht Gründe die
überzeugend sind die kenne ich nicht
insofern wäre es völlig vermessen wenn
ich jetzt sage geben Sie ihm meinen
Kärtchen ich helfe ihm ich kann ihm dann
kann ein Brief schreiben an die
werbeauftragtes kann er übrigens auch
tun und
auch getan meine Antwort werden na gut
das ist natürlich nicht gut weil das
dafür
die Soldaten und Soldaten zu kümmern
aber also da muss man sich einfach
angucken was ist eigentlich die
Begründung der Bundeswehr für diese
Impfpflicht und die kenne ich nicht also
da bin ich zu sehr langes Politikerin
als dass ich tatsächlich jetzt eben
impfpfähle der Bundeswehr kenn